the honeydew with Ryan Sickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it at studio night pants
I am Ryan Sickler and I know I know you
want me to say at your mom's house hell
I want to say it I said it for a year
and a half of course it's difficult for
me to even say it but I tried something
different I likes to I'm in the indie in
the would you say the in the vein and
honor of your mom's house with studio
jeans I thought we'd go studio night
pants okay
let's try something all right I know
you're gonna stay at your mom's house is
it I did make a nice little ringy
catchphrase but anyway thank you all for
your support thank you for being here
please go subscribe to the YouTube
channel youtube.com slash our Sickler
also make sure you're subscribed to the
Facebook fan page as well get over there
we're gonna have content there as well
and if you haven't submitted your story
or subscribe to the patreon yet please
go do that the new show is called the
honeydew with y'all where I highlight
the lowlights
with y'all you could submit your email
at honeydew podcast at gmail.com go to
Ryan Sickler calm honey new podcast calm
you can subscribe there I've already
talked to an old friend whose dad came
out in his late 40s I talked to a girl
who had two [ __ ] I've talked to quite
a few people we're gonna be bringing it
to y'all every Thursday it goes up on
patreon alright and I can't thank you
again for all of your support merch
night pants nation I mean y'all are
[ __ ] rolling out I hope everybody's
comfortable [ __ ] cuz I swear to you
their quality night pants go to honeydew
podcast.com or Ryan Sickler calm in the
merch store get yourself a pair of night
pants I record here at the Santa Monica
Music Center and I can't thank you again
there's so many of you have helped the
messages the donations everything uh the
honeydew strong shirt of course I can't
forget that that's also available in the
merch store proceeds from that shirt go
to benefit the Santa Monica Music Center
and if you're out there and you're
looking for lessons go to Santa Monica
music com get a lesson get a lesson for
you get a lesson for the kid
he'll take lessons with your kids
connect with your damn kids okay learn
something you all can play guitar
together you know maybe you're in the
woodwinds I don't know maybe you like
the clarinet grab the licorice stick go
play something okay if you're in Indiana
and you want your kids or yourself to be
trained by a kick-ass Los Angeles
musician this is the place to go they're
a family owned business been here for 50
years serving the community they do
great programs you can hear about all
that all right because the show is all
about highlighting the low lights and I
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers and today's guest is my
good friend and owner of the Santa
Monica Music Center ladies and gentlemen
Lata agretti
welcome to the honeydew podcast Lana
thank you I appreciate you being here
we're gonna talk about everything that
happened you know there's been a crazy
time in our lives beginning with corona
so before we get to that we're gonna
tell your story you're you're a great
friend of mine you're so good to my
daughter's mother or family my daughter
everybody but your I've always
fascinated me laugh my ass off over
there like when I first met you I knew
you were cool when I was like I'm trying
to stroll my daughter and you were like
oh he's fun he's booked us I was like
okay long but anyway let's go back to
the beginning for you you're born and
raised here in Santa Monica and just
talk tell us your story station 26 is
what I like to say that's not where I
was born but I was definitely raised by
the beach station 26 is that the
lifeguard station five car station which
by the way the original one got
partially burned so they replaced it
with another one but yeah my mom came
here when she was no she came to America
from Trinidad when she was a teenager
sixteen or so by the time they went from
Florida to Georgia she experienced a lot
of racism in Georgia she was not allowed
to swim in the pool so wait cuz I know
your mom now it's funny cuz any is also
here by the way and and he's gonna be
joining us for a part of the story too
any thought you're a white lady
hmm no no I know those highlights are
good I mean my mom is from Trinidad and
she's so she's West Indian but your
mom's not she wasn't allowed to swim in
the pushy cuz I don't your mom doesn't
look like my grandpa okay so her dad's
darker than any for sure and so they
called them a straight haired n-word and
that's okay so so seeing your mom with
your dad was like you're not with my
grandpa I mean great yeah so I heard
that but it was actually just seeing my
mom because she's dark
she's just older now maybe I'll show you
older pictures of her but my mom was
dark long black hair and and there was
seven of them her siblings you do the
accent I know in the fore side yeah the
first time I heard you dude I was like
oh it's a good impression then I
realized oh no that's not an impression
it's a present for mom know what I love
about that is that we grew up calling
our vagina a pokey cuz that's what they
call it pokey and Totti and I remember
figuring out that it was actually a
vagina and so then I told my friends
like we would go around and ask boys
like so do you have a pokey or a toady
and then if they answered it you know
like I got a pokey or what do you like
better you know they said yeah I like a
toady but yeah my mom we grew up with a
little bit of the accent it was already
fading away she really wanted to
assimilate into American culture why why
did your mom come here or why her family
well they lived in carinii Village so if
some people don't even know where to
turn it out in Tobago is it's a small
island
Brian I've been yeah we went back and I
was like this is miserable
she literally they repaired patches and
and there I wouldn't want to say hut but
where they lived it was like shantytown
they repaired patches with her job was
to get cow dung and mud you mix it and
that's how you repaired the patches in
your house she didn't get shoes till she
was like ten so um you know she was from
a little village they bathed in a pipe
in the road she killed chickens for real
yeah for real like that's they they went
to the bathroom in an outhouse look up
carinii village so it's in a crazy that
like it seems like so long ago but it's
not none of this [ __ ] is
and none of it she tried to be
vegetarian really easy to snap chickens
next she's like it was organic Wow
but she so she came from a superb rural
background and she came here all smiles
that's that Caribbean smile and was
horrified by American culture from day
one so why did they come thinking for a
better life okay I mean and they went
they got straight to Georgia well they
went to Florida first go in sections you
know and to find work and my mom my
grandmother my mom would clean motel
rooms and then when they met they went
to Georgia they lived in the house in
Georgia I don't know if you know of the
film from the 60s and 70s Big Ben or the
bear yeah of course
they lived in it was a rundown
dilapidated you weren't supposed to live
in there there was probably mold that's
more later gonna find out they lived it
out yeah right so they let this poor
little family come in Little House on
the Prairie house I'll be back yeah you
can make a living out of living all of
those old so there was parts of the
house that you couldn't even go into so
I mean they lived there my mom has some
great that's crazy really they lived in
that was all they could afford I mean
people couldn't figure out what they
were racially like they were super dark
but they weren't black but they weren't
you know white and they weren't Mexican
they weren't Indian they're like what
the hell are these people with this
Caribbean accent I mean I grew up a
white kid and I didn't know I first knew
it was all through soccer that's soccer
and Maryland was where I started to see
diversity and Dominican kids and and we
had and then with the Baltimore blast at
this guy'll never get his name was
Richard Chinna poo and he was from
Trinidad and that's when I learned cuz
he was [ __ ] good you know and I'm
like God and he looked at the little
BIOS that's how they say but yeah my mom
you know by the time that she got to
California she was 18
and I mean I think she met my dad at 17
and a half but we won't go into that and
my dad's like 13 years older than her
oh really yeah and she was into American
[Laughter]
he's four wives later no but he was he
was a musician a drummer and he was
playing at Charlie Brown's anybody who's
been around a long time will know what
that is my dad had opened up Clockwork
Orange that was a that was the movie
okay so wait so hold on so your mom's
family relocates out here yes and you
know where they were at 18 or does she
go on her own no the whole family family
all came together first where do they go
in the motel on Rose and Lincoln right
next to lockup Anya nah yep five kids
and two adults the seven of them they
cooked they had a hot plate that you
would not a hot plate a stove thing you
used for camping that they would put on
the back of the toilet and that's how
they would cook their meals in the motel
and my mom my dad my grandma seven of
them five kids there's a whole history
between like my I have a half-black
uncle because my grandma at 15 she was a
little hussy
she had a kid young and then so that he
he's also an additional uncle that we
grew up with later on like they sent for
him and then she has another half my
grandma had a couple kids before I like
apparently really young back then it was
okay um you know you had your period you
were ready to have babies so that's what
mother nature said but the five of them
like my my uncle's a manse they lived in
that motel my grandpa was a taxi driver
at some point he got a job I don't know
how being in a driver's ed teacher we
call drivers oh wow cuz he drives a to
fees to drive her two feet he's out here
anymore but yeah my mom they lived there
right here and we still live right up
the street from it then they lived on
Copeland Court which is behind blick
which now those properties are worth
like Oh Lian's god yeah and they kicked
themselves because they had an
opportunity to buy it back then they
were so afraid you know immigrant family
my mom met my dad being a groupie at
going out with her friends so around the
Santa Mon
lar your dad was already here oh yeah he
was here he came from Canada and he has
a crazy story yeah I want to hear
because your dad came from Canada but
he's he's so he's born and raised Canada
but their background is Spanish Spaniard
and Cuban through like they had Cuban
cigars
we had Fernandez we have the little like
labels so his parents are from Cuba they
know into chaos man Spanish Spaniard I
think at some point somebody went to
Cuba and almost found me born there but
it's really from like Spain and then his
his mother has English background and
all that so he's Toronto that's where he
was and he had another great diverse
City it's wrong yes diverse so he had
son at 15 but I'll cut to that later on
nobody knew about it it was like back
then she got pregnant young and her the
girl he got pregnant that her mother ran
a house for girls who got pregnant out
of wedlock they like hid her away had
the baby quickly put it up for adoption
and so like my grandmother apparently my
dad can we come back to that cuz I've
ever connect he found us ok rolled up
it's a dog going junk in the store
someone's here you wanted Chico's kid he
was like a Al Gore tell me when that
internet [ __ ] ready bro I'm ready god oh
my god so anyways my dad was a crazy
musician the black sheep of the family
we have a real Catholic family everyone
on my dad's side was you know pretty
straight-laced you know volunteer and in
the church and my dad was like from the
jump he was the drummer I mean he was
the rock and roll kid of the family um
so when he left Toronto he went all over
I mean my dad played on the stage when
they used to have live drums for
strippers to go out you know my dad
played a little like titty swing yeah my
dad and then like gave some of the girls
who knows my dad's massager you see
these double D's I gotta add two three
well that's like--that's Chico Chico I
love those names [ __ ] what's his real
name
birth name but no one's called him that
he got Chico is Chico Fernandes because
of a baseball player my dad's little
mommy he's at one point he might have
been 5 to 5 jockey yeah so yeah he did
photography as a kid he did play drums
by the time he got here he was still
doing some photography you'll see it if
you ever go to his place he just liked
capturing things you know like a
homeless man sleeping or something like
that whatever it was but he also liked
to do head shots for anyone any
musicians he played with so my dad's
goal was you know to be in that
entertainment industry so he makes
what's he play drums drums drums and
Tomales he plays Latin jazz and American
jazz so he ended up hooking up and
having a couple kids with one of them
stripper girl yeah and she left him they
lived they lived in a in a how many
brothers and sisters do you have I have
two half I have a half brother and a
half sister another half brother the one
that we found out about later and then
my full brother and then we don't know
we all were always like I've met your
brother
yeah I've ever met anyone else Rhonda
no maybe you might have met Rhonda I
don't think so she's an Oxnard so she
doesn't come down a lot but when he got
with her they lived in a like an RV
thing that like attaches to a car and
she left him one night with the kids
with toddlers in that yeah he's like you
got the car now I don't have anywhere to
go so he was stuck with two kids like
babies changing
he said he he was changing their diapers
on the side of like the 60 freeway you
know on the hood of a car and change him
on the tow your mom's back there cooking
she left him I mean he has stories about
dealing with the Mafia people and all
this kind of stuff in there she was
connected and that way she was like
Italian whatever em so then he he
traveled with them a little bit
he ended up sending them to Toronto for
a little bit tell my grandma take care
of him while he like situated himself
and then he met Lisa his second wife
who's african-american she raised
my half-brother and half-sister for the
most part I'm wrong I remember talking
your dad about how yeah black girls and
I'm right there with right there with
Eugene and he likes to tell everybody
he's all speaking of black lives matter
I'm like okay even I I'd say all the
time like I always thought I'd end up
with a mix kid I just think it'd be
somebody else's well my dad doesn't
discriminate cuz we got my mom from
Trinidad Italian Lisa and then Elena who
is with who's Filipino so so the second
wife this is a wife yeah Lisa and she
pretty much raised Ronda and Paul or
mine a half-brother no sister um so they
were together for a long time and then
at some point I think I'm sorry Lisa
raised the stripper who's bounced yeah
exactly
she didn't come into the picture till
way later after death I think someone
like found Ron in them so so then he
breaks up with Lisa and he's now on the
road again he's in Vegas he's playing
you know nightclubs whatever all this
stuff my dad's also by the way now been
in bands that are opened for Dionne
Warwick at the time I mean he's played
with a lot of greats so he's played
later on even with you know like in the
same lineup with Tito Puente and sell a
cruise so I remember as a kid being
behind the stage at Hollywood Bowl with
those people in the that's great because
I went to a Playboy Jazz Festival one
time and I watched Tito Puente and
Sheila E can't I was fantastic I'll bet
yours was years ago but it was awesome I
always remember that one because my
brother smoke some weed backstage and he
passed out and hit his head and it like
kind of [ __ ] up my dad's like
interview thing we were gonna go and
things like god damn it ray got high on
the wrong weed and [ __ ] like it's like
that's what he was burned about it but I
always remember that I'm like I was too
young and I like who was the wrong well
is it okay that he gets to get high can
we start there I couldn't even watch TV
for an extra half hour um but no he um
so to back up then he met my mom she was
she was 17 okay I don't know it was
easier to get into bars back then but
just from her she was going out while
I'm spun-out
like go follow this band that my dad
play with Charlie Brown's was the spot
back in the day and then there was
Clockwork Orange which after the movie
came out my dad opened up this bar club
called Clockwork Orange with some
friends and where was that I don't know
I think it was either between here and
Malibu it was like West LA it's all on
this side so we have pictures of it in
the store that's chemical here's a lot
of history but you could do a three-hour
episode on my dad alone he's he'll throw
out names you haven't heard of and big
names but they ended up together and
they had my brother first I mean they
lived together and dated and all that
stuff had my brother like he was six at
the wedding he was in the wedding my
brother always talks about that I
realized when I looked at pictures and
it wasn't any big wedding it was a local
thing outside he's like listen isn't
number three man I'm I'm done actually
exactly Lisa was still a part of my now
my mom she was only a few years older
than my pfaff sister that was the crazy
part yeah yes and they used to go to
blows like they'd be fighting over stuff
and yeah and my dad was playing late
nights and stumbling and drunk and my
mom she always tells us a story about
how she get upset and my dad you know
for being out all night and drinking so
he'd pass out on the couch and she'd
roll up newspapers and wake up Paul and
Rhonda and maybe my brother at that
point and they'd like beat the [ __ ] out
of him with the newspaper like all that
[ __ ] she couldn't say during the day and
that was when they would unite together
you know but my sister oh my god she
stole the car and one time I think my
mom was like I was mad at your dad so I
was like let's go together and steal his
credit card like you know they were like
the same age almost and my brother now
they were a dog town like it was right
here you know right by station 26 where
he grew up
and that was when like the dog town yeah
just coming up I love that about
California you guys I mean you really
that's the whole culture out here okay
you were just telling me recently that
there's some was it a display or
something where you there were pictures
of you that you took your daughters
I passed away that's like big in the
skate dog town community and they were
doing like everybody was submitting
pictures on it it was more about my
brother but I'm in it and I'm like
barefoot and dirty I mean I didn't get
to have a lot of his time because he was
so much older than me but he did throw
me in zuma beach and teach me you know
how to surf
by literally throwing me out when there
was a Riptide that was a scariest thing
he's like you'll be fine and Luther
carry you out 50 feet or you could swim
diagonals he was crazy but he was you
know kicked out of every school he went
to the alternative school house which is
now smash it's called now is known for
like kids get to wear their pajamas it's
an alternative learning thing or night
pants exactly where I'd want to [ __ ]
go but before it was for the kids who
were like you know kicked out of every
classroom that was him and I mean my
sister was the one who like sketched out
on the beach you know the first like
beginnings of the dog town logo like he
was a part of that yeah I love that that
is awesome
that's they were part of that whole its
history that the surf shop on Main
Street you know like those guys starting
it he was part of that whole you know in
the the pools getting caught going in
the empty pools so I looked up to him
because I thought he was cool but he was
scary right he was scary he was
definitely getting into drugs what's
your age difference god we're probably
about 13 years oh wow or maybe 11 and
then she's like 13 she's older so he
eventually went so far off into drugs
and stuff that we spent we saw him less
and less unfortunately um but
nonetheless I looked up to him because
that whole skate culture that whole
thing was super cool I mean yeah and I
told you Lenny Kravitz was lived across
the street from us for a while that was
all their group that was that group of
people that live right there um so then
yes and my mom and dad are together and
my dad's trying to convince my mom's
parents my grandparents too like you
should buy a home so they ended up
buying this duplex property in Lawndale
not in a nice neighborhood
I never paid attention to that till I
became an adult and that's where all my
memories were made like my whole life I
think about my grandparents house I mean
my mom my grandmother made traditional
Trinidadian food so it was like roti
pulao curry chicken all the time she was
just constantly cooking out of a huge
big steel pot always had parties we had
steel pan which is what they play in
Trinidad yeah we had steel pan players
live like are hot that house my
grandma's house was the party house when
we look forward every weekend we went
there my aunt lived in the front or my
uncle depending on who was living in the
front house and they lived in the back
house and I just that's for one I also
looked forward to it because we got to
get McDonald's my mom was healthy before
I was in style so every Friday we go to
Lawndale and the first thing my grandpa
would do he'd get us a happy meal yeah
so that's where for me like if I think
of my youth I think of going to Grandma
grandpa's on the weekend um it wasn't
until middle school that I invited some
of my white friends to come to Grandma
and Grandpa I was thinking like come
check out my grandma's house it's so
much fun there there's always parties
and that we have a DJ that would be like
a steel pan and everyone's dancing and
I'll never forget when they were like
first of all where's the utensils and
why do you eat with this tortilla thing
and why is there plastic that's sticky
on your grandma's table I was like a lot
of judgment here and like oh the carpets
like my socks are black I'll never
forget my friends like my socks are
black walking on your grandma's carted
off like it is we it always like that we
were a black socks so we don't see it
why did you bring white socks
I remember for the first time that was
the first time I thought about race
culture we had never talked about it we
weren't one thing we're so eclectic we
weren't waving one flag in front of our
house there was so many nice really
interesting yeah you were already in
such a diverse eclectic right you know
you said something to me one time I
wanted to remind you I don't know if you
remember but you said there was some
someone made you feel horrible about
your knees yes well this was around well
that was elementary school actual that
was my first interaction there was this
girl who I guess I just won't mention
her name
we all had a sleepover at her house and
a white girl a white girl and she lived
in a nice side of North Amman Tana and
there was another friend there that was
african-american and she was saying some
things to her about like she should put
peroxide on her arm hairs or something
like that and then she got to me and she
was like well your mom's a [ __ ] and I
was like whoa I didn't even know what
that was I was like her back is wet
because she I really thought that it was
cuz my mom would sweat cuz she did a
hair I'm like are they making fun of my
mom cuz she's sweaty like I had to ask
my mom about that the next day and that
was a whole other thing but she told me
well you're you're so dark in the summer
like your knees get so dark they look
dirty all the time you why don't you do
something about it cuz they look dirty I
was like I don't think I can do anything
about it it's just how they look when
they fold and I went home and she's like
well you could bleach him and I remember
getting a quarter cup of bleach and
scrubbing the basically the skin off my
knees cuz it burns you I don't know that
and trying to explain to my mom why I
was doing it and you know she was like
she always felt a little bit like that
about my dad's mom kind of would make my
mom feel like about her she'd always
mentioned her dark skin really yeah
that's which is interesting I mean isn't
it crazy that like all the [ __ ] you
worry about it as a kid like and the
insecurities like you remember that
forever forever you'll remember that
forever someone making you feel about
your knees and then you look back at it
and now you're like how how [ __ ] oh
my gosh stupid I [ __ ] up my knees and
also how ignorant this girl is is being
raised by these people you know
believing that dark skin is is somehow
bad you
got a lightning you know she also did
some other horrible stuff which may be
too deep for this show but there ain't
nothin ok well this room that was my
introduction to molestation - at that
girl's house she why we were in the bath
together we had a bathing suits on
because that's what you do at that age
and how old are you at this point 1112 I
mean 11 probably 11 and so yeah oh no
wait came out when it was 12 so 10 and
1/2 11 like me is it yeah yeah and she's
like discussing if her private parts and
all this stuff and she's got the faucet
on there and I'm kind of like this is
weird you know so she goes go to the
kitchen and get a hot dog and a zip and
a sandwich bag and I'm like I okay I'm
gonna
in my mind we were as adults for like oh
[ __ ] out of here right now that's five
years.when out for me I don't really
know like I did turkey dogs yeah I know
you're about to tell us this but
whatever you're about to tell us what's
blowing the array away right now is disc
organization she's got a routine bring
out a ziploc bag the zipper Chi it was
just a full kind but you know it was
safe so so go get off I don't get it
that might call slippery in the kitchen
and [ __ ] like we get nachos
I come back in and I'm like okay and she
puts it in the sandwich bag oh my god
she's using it like I had what but now
mind you I have no idea in a million
years that where this is going and she
starts to put it inside her she's like
standing up it's like halfway hey look
you do it I was like that is so [ __ ]
was our first of all like things can go
inside that hole I'm thinking you pee
and you [ __ ] from the same area
that's your first time ever you know
yeah
ever in your life right let alone a hot
dog of a sandwich bag I'm so blown away
by all of it so I was so uncomfortable
and I felt sick in my stomach and I knew
I knew there was something wrong but I
couldn't figure it out and so listen she
reached over almost kind of I was like
oh this is don't touch me I don't like
it and I'm moving on and I slept with my
eyes open that whole night now the
reason I was there was because my mom
and dad were divorced at that point I
know we kind of skipped over that but
she was working in the film industry so
she got a makeup job and it took her to
Alaska for a week she was doing it
because you know we were apartment to
apartment all the time so unfortunately
I always think back I don't know why I
didn't just stay at my dad's he was up
the street but for whatever reason it
would be like I'd go to a friend's and
all of my friends you stay for like the
week yeah so her house was the worst I
mean her brother would like shoot
paintballs towards us on the outside
yeah she had a snake and would make it
regurgitate she would like watch this
feed it fish and you would watch him
then she'd like make it come back up and
I was like oh [ __ ] her [ __ ] and
squeezes [ __ ] out of the chute easy like
the snake might be in the bed with you
so like and I'd be like oh [ __ ] I can't
go to sleep what happened to this girl
you still talk to her no she's my
daughter's godmother
thank you for your subscription we
appreciate your part of my pants crazy
part is hey hold on real quick we do
have a hole an opening in the in the
[ __ ] hole area you want to slide your
hotdogs in without taking them off I got
you nice pan strange you don't want to
get Salmonella
over that that is that do you think that
was taught Oh what do you think you
remember the McMartin case
okay it was a preschool in Manhattan
Beach it supposedly had molested all
these kids and they took him to an
underground thing and cut her she was
supposedly one of those kids okay and
her mom was like on Geraldo behind a
screen but then they found out that it
was all lies they like ruin these
people's life what yeah like
two-year-olds were like being like did
they cut off bunny ears and they're like
and then you know these this whole
family's life now listen anybody
watching or listening listen McMartins
if you subscribe I'm not this is her
penis it may be that they did or didn't
I don't I remember it coming out that
they didn't so that all these kids had
felt lied or whatever okay we're wrong a
lot on this show
but obviously something happened yeah
clearly something happened so but cut to
she's out of sleep over again goddamn
what I can't cuz yours again okay so I
asked you you didn't go home and tell
your mom that's what also scares me
every not every but I would say 9 out of
10 people that sit across from me always
say drop nothing well the trauma
happened to I'm scared to tell somebody
and it's like oh it seems so obvious I
tell Stella that all the time like I
think you're gonna come tell me but you
may not but I want you to know you can I
always tell her if you're if you're
honest I'll you'll never be in trouble
if you're honest and this is the crazy
part because it's a girl everyone thinks
if some old man asks you to sit on his
lap or that's what it right right so if
it doesn't look like that then you're
not sure what just happened like how do
you go tell somebody I just told you I'm
dying laughing like well we were in the
bath and then she said get a hot dog
I've never was like wait is like him so
you know the whole thing was wet and it
was embarrassing you feel shame sure cuz
you're confused like why was I in that
situation she was just mean and she was
the ringleader but she lived in a rich
part of the neighborhood as did all my
friends I was the only one that had an
apartment maybe there was one other girl
that did but in this group of friends
you know my mom made sure I bused to
that school because she thought hanging
out with rich white people I hang out
with the Jewish kids you'll be better
off she wanted to expose me right that's
the mentality coming here she was like
that like okay let me make friends with
yes go meet everyone isolate right they
keep tears right don't be hanging out
with these kids in the apartment we got
enough of that so she was like go over
here and I will attest that there was
great things cuz I used to go to the
with the same girls family to the horse
races and learned about betting on
horses for a dollar or whatever and I
never had the stuff you're supposed to
wear they're like do you have nice flats
on my Twitter flats you know so there
was good things to it but she one night
when we were
having that sleepover set all those
racist things cut to a couple years
later there was drama as girls have in
middle school and I told a school
counselor finally what had happened with
the hot dog with the hot dog and she
apparently did her due diligence called
the police made a full-on report
interviewed like half of my friends and
then I was like oh my god
like this was a long time ago so things
are probably different now so how long
again I'm sorry how long from the time
it happened and they go two years like
one half okay cuz if I was fifth going
into sixth grade and this was like we're
on seventh grade that she's you know
said something so now my friends know so
but we were all like trying to be
everyone had figured out on their own
like she's not nice I don't wanna be
friends with her and the counselor was
trying to like get in it and I just
broke down and was like well let me tell
you I don't like her it's not cuz she
did this at lunch she tried to take a
hotdog in my vagina this is like a movie
because what ended up happening is what
eleven-year-old is gonna keep that a
secret even your own friends sooner or
later that's go out after the whole it
was supposed to be quiet they got the
cops interviewing and I'm having to tell
the story like 27 times cuz it's so
bizarre I guess they want to make sure
not lying
I go to school after three days of like
interrogation on it and everyone's
singing OSCA our house and two hot dogs
on it was like it was like in protection
it was horrible
I was like I'm never gonna live this
down I did oh that was my like and I
remember I'll never forget I don't
remember so much my mom I think she felt
really guilty like you should have told
me like why did you want to keep going
to that [ __ ] house I was like I
don't know I mean I used to pretend like
I was having nightmares in the room with
her she had a trundle bed and I had run
across the house and crawl in bed with
her mom because I was scared of
like she was either gonna put the snake
in my bed or hot dog up open a bag of
snacks I like [ __ ] where's that going so
yeah I mean that was my first experience
but I guess it's even to this day feels
weird to say like molested but they're
like that's what it was I'm like really
like somebody touched you or whatever
tried did something that you didn't want
them to do so so now do you I don't know
I'm telling you I'm not a big hot dog
Fanny I get about 2/3 a year and usually
it's at a sporting event
you got plastic oh I'm sorry
just make sure hot dogs am I gonna
ziploc bag like duh oh my god was she
she then everybody fancy about it what
she's mortified okay so she's she wife I
usually yeah she leaves a school she
goes to a private school
local now less than a year later I'm at
a bus stop on 20th and Pico and she rose
up with Em's which is if you're not
Mexican you don't know what it is that's
how we'd spray our hair have you're
trying to be a chola gangster back in
the day she rolls up on me and I'm just
like dude do do it waiting at the bus
and she's like she claims I don't want
to say it on here the local gang but in
Spanish in my face so she's like Santa
Monica the sec yet they boot that I'm
like oh my god you speak Spanish like
this was that was my first thought was a
[ __ ]
I'm so confused like you speak about it
so she's rolls up and says it to me and
she's with these like gangster girls and
I'm like what is happening right what
happened to you like he went to private
school this is what happened - so she
had turned what are you putting up your
[ __ ] she so then she tried to come and
roll up on me at school and that went my
first fight and all the kids the whole
school got into a fistfight with her not
with her because of course it
like the alcohol that she said yeah and
I had a box cutter knife and that was
not a nice moment but you got cut no
this girl told me I well I guess I want
to say her name but I can't she has such
a cool name but anyway she was like
listen
well she's not around anymore we don't
know their first name Consuelo so she
was like listen they're outside for you
here's this box she was helping you put
in your hand like this when you saw her
just on the side I was I wanted to [ __ ]
my pants I had like children which is
like diarrhea it's but I mean I just was
like like my awesome sounds like you
were in a like like what do you call it
when they send you away to school what
do you call reform school or whatever
yeah the Blue Ribbon best you know
schools here so they're like you gotta
go that day after school when they came
that was separate from the bus stop I
already was like oh something's happened
to her like she's changing the I was
trying to like stay late cuz I knew they
were trying to jump me outside I was
asking the teacher so unquestioned 92 is
like um you've been here for a long time
are you okay I was like I'm just
wondering if there's extra credit do you
need help organizing that's when
Consuela's like you're gonna have to
face it like these girls were in high
school they were like five years older
than me they wanted listen I'm either
getting stabbed or I'm getting a hot dog
oh yeah I don't want either one of these
things could you take me to my car give
it a dog meat I was like so mortified to
go out there cuz I didn't know what I
was gonna run into but I dealt with it
head-on and that story got twisted it
was so funny cuz people were like oh she
came out there and like I did it all
gangster and I was like really I was
scared shitless it got stuck and I was
off oh my god I like let it go and ran
but it wasn't in her it was you know
another girl that was with her so that
you stopped away with it you did yeah
but it just got right there and I was
like you know and I freaked out so I
didn't want anything like you know I
didn't want to have that fight but the
following year that my middle school
year was so crazy the following year I
have another group of friends here's cut
to these rich white kids I was like
thanks mom so I'm hanging out with them
and I'm it's nutrition seven
great yeah and a seventh-grade Nomad can
have a sippy your soda to a really good
friend a guy friend he gives me sip he's
all you can finish it I drink it next
period I'm feeling weird I'm like poking
some kid by the period after that I'm
its computer class and every time you
started the computer these little wheels
would go and they fell off the screen
onto the floor and I was like oh [ __ ]
that is not supposed to happen I start
sinking into my seat because I think I'm
melting
he put a bunch of tabs of acid nah ha
and I'm 12
I'm I got hot dogs of acid holy Sh I
don't know what's happening I'm dying I
think I'm dying so they so was he also
was he dreaming in the classroom and he
sees me and I'm running a people is he
tripping he was - ok so he I wanted it
or it was funny and I don't know why I
did it but it ruined his life after that
cuz that's I mean he put so many tabs
that it could have been attempted murder
no problem they had to like pump my
stomach in the whole thing
wait walk us through well I'm in that
computer class and now I'm like this
doesn't feel right I feel like the floor
is eating me now mind you I've never
done drugs
I'm a little kid so I'm thinking I got
food poisoning I'm really dying so I run
to the teacher and we're up on the top
floor and I grab him and I'm pulling his
shirt down I'm like something's wrong
with me help me and the kid who did it
is in the class with me and I'm like
looking at him and he's freaking out I
go straight for the window which is the
roof over the school and they jump can't
just run I don't I just had to run so
they were pulling me pulling me they
tear apart they're going through what I
ate they're tearing apart the cafeteria
the you know because I was on free and
reduced lunch um I had to get the free
lunch - oh my god everyone's like why do
you really pay 35 cents I was like what
I had a coupon code used to get the
green they may just take a green ticket
and it's nice running everybody so [ __ ]
is so terrible that milk is bomb and so
I'm over there at the vending machine
they're like you know what did you have
in the vetting machine they're checking
it out the cops are there try to hotdog
oh my god they end up getting it out of
somebody and they open his locker and he
has acid and more well like someone
snitched on it yeah but I'm saying he's
got more and right I guess is crying I
didn't even know these kids did that how
was he your eleven twelve okay so I'm
like and you know these are the kids
that like nutrition were bending over
listening to Nirvana and like like
trying to fixate themselves for like
putting [ __ ] in his drink but so he gets
he's like zip-tied and my mom comes from
Trinidad hey wait so they figure it out
the police come and get him right away
they're coming to me now they're looking
at my eye they're like mmhmm yep yeah
and I'm thinking like they know
something it's all crazy I think like
everyone's talking about you around you
or whatever and they're like yeah yeah
it's you know acid or whatever
LSD we found it my mom they're trying to
talk to my mom my mom's like I'm not
gonna do anything to him I know him it's
seriously it's fine let me just say
something to him all of a sudden my mom
is sliding across the like an
administration table to reach him to
just attack the [ __ ] out of him and
they're like yes you know so my mom's
gone crazy and that was not the first
time my mom and the school district you
know my brother got job - my mom was
like I just want to talk to them exactly
so so what happens - it's taken and he's
young and my parents knew his parents
and it was a rough situation because my
parents believe in mistakes listen my
brother had made tons of mistakes and
when I was telling you about and went to
juvie and I think many times my parents
probably wished that someone gave him a
pass he got in trouble keeping got
expelled from the whole school I think
had to go to a boarding school and you
know his mom was horrified like it was a
whole thing was a sad thing but we could
have made it worse with litigation we
just didn't I wasn't say were there
charges or I didn't have anything to
take and he's a minor and so he dealt
with legally having possession on his
own but so my mom of course being the
hippie that she is she's like we're
gonna journal this experience so I'm
like having the journal and I'm like
then I'm just talking to me my friend
was supposed to spend the night that
night
you still have that [ __ ] Journal and
it's crazy the writing looks all it's
all going off to the best part though is
my friend Samantha's supposed to sleep
over and she's standing there we had
were like matching like cross color you
know overalls that day she's like she's
hot
am I still spending the night on my
[ __ ] imma be trippin for three days so
she had to stay it was crazy but he came
back to school a couple months later to
visit and the entire school chased him
till he peed his pants in this house
they were like we got you Lana
we're chasing I just became like a
movement like I didn't even know why we
were running for I'm like why does
everybody want to kick his ass you know
how that goes everybody's like
somebody's asked to get they felt like
damn you did her dirty I didn't want to
have that I don't know if it was a prank
or he thought I'd like it but that
probably set me up for not needing to
try hard drugs I was cool alcohol I'll
bet ya never tried cocaine me either
I mean I've done nearly I don't need it
no you don't you got you got cocaine in
it exactly so I just never I don't know
if it was that experience but it was bad
enough for me to be like I'm good like I
don't need to have I don't like that
feeling of being in control not in
control so that was that was that and
that was after my parents got divorced
so but well good doesn't say but while I
was doing sleep what was it like when
your parents were divorced did you cuz
you're close with your dad so was he
good about going back and forth or were
you with your mom most the time or how
was that weird like in comparison to
what people have these arrangements with
days and weekends I mean like me yeah
exactly with two to three five to two I
heard my friends talking abouth and I'm
like I have no idea are you talking
about days of the week so I was eight my
dad my brother was like 13 or 14
probably 14 anyways when I found out it
was like what I remember I got out of
the car that day and like ran towards
Patton's there used to be a patents on
Montana at TCBY and I was devastated my
whole world first of all a friend had
just told me that Santa Claus wasn't
real problems like let me tell she goes
she said and divorce she told me before
my parents got divorced she had said in
Devore
is when your dad moves to Oklahoma and
you gotta see him like only on the break
oh yeah right right
there's no [ __ ] so my mom it was
devastating my mom got up one Saturday
morning and like left but she did leave
us she just left and like I think talked
to my grandparents we were in her van
like her minivan
the bizarre thing was the way it worked
out was my mom felt like I was still
little so I would go with her and my
brother was older and maybe it would be
better off with my dad which as a mother
now I look back and think I wonder if
that was hard for my brother I've asked
him before I'm not knowing that that
time my brother was struggling with
coming out right yeah so he was doing
acid and all kinds of drugs at that time
so it was crazy I felt really bad for my
dad I remember feeling really sad for
him like you're gonna be lonely cut to a
year later he's like I got me a new wife
don't worry about me was it a year like
that like in Vegas he likes to get
married he just gets married and he
stays like my parents were together 15
years they've been together him and
Elena have been together since I was
like 10 so like 30 years oh wow yeah so
and then my mom we slept on the floor of
my grandparents we slept on the floor of
her friend Tina's apartment building I
always remembered it smelled like rotten
milk in there I was like did they
spilled milk on this car right here I
mean we moved around and our first
little apartment was behind what is now
a Starbucks a drive-through Starbucks on
Pico it used to be a Kentucky Fried
Chicken and all that one right there
that one right there I used to be
Kentucky Fried Chicken in that wall
that's there used to be a chain-link
wobbly fence and we would hear people
ordering all night and I used to love to
get on my bike and I would go over
through the junk yeah I remember yeah
that wasn't that long though it was at a
KFC yeah yeah you lived in those
apartments here like there uh it's like
a not a duplex there's three little
units little one-bedroom tiny units our
first night there there was a drive-by
and I used to be a really bad
neighborhood over there and then you
know all night long you know cuz I lived
where I lived all the time you know we
were in an apartment before but now I'm
in this new environment it felt scary
the guys next door used to fight all the
time you'd hear them fighting and
screaming there was always cops there
they would beat the [ __ ] there were two
there were guys that were dating each
other and
there was drugs and cocaine going on in
there someone broke in and tried to like
the neighbor broke into the other
neighbor's house and stole a TV like it
was scary to live there um it was
definitely scary and the huh I just
remember always going to they used to
get so mad at Kentucky Fried Chicken cuz
I would go through the drive-thru with
my bag I'm like can I get the little
those little baby Mick chickens it was
like a turtle's like you can't they'd
stick they're half the window from a
head you can't do like premier Mike wide
so that was my experience there and then
my mom was just always like you know she
dated someone and that was the thing I
was like I my whole thing with her and
she knows this so I can say it if she
listens it's like I just want it to be
enough like I'm going through a family
breakup could you just can we just be us
you know I'm already dealing with the
going back and forth happened but it was
like every Sunday my dad would take my
brother and I bowling at the bowling
alley which is now turned into a
ridiculously it's like $80 I know it's
stupid I still have my own bowling bag
and shoes that we got at a garage sale
to this day do you yeah now it only
saves you like a dollar 25 got my bag
they're like okay exactly
but like it's $40 though I was like oh
[ __ ] so we used to do that and my dad
would take us for a chocolate malt at
callaghan's which is now INGOs tasty
diner that our friends that grew up in
the you know community in Santa Monica
owned forever when my friend passed away
not that long ago her dad couldn't take
it and keep the restaurant anymore but
they kept the callaghan's look so it's
still there so that's I grew up right
here like this was all yeah you're born
and raised well we were sick we slept on
the couch at the Music Store you know we
have Nana's blanket like we did our
homework here after school there's to be
a Arby's it was always like we get the
potato triangles and a jamocha shake
from Arby's that's how I think of you
know growing up here there was just all
in this little ten block radius but that
experience is my mom and being divorced
was you know her first boyfriend Wally
who she knows to this day I swear to god
he's to hug her and look at me and go
and wink his eye and I was like are you
[ __ ] with me like and he probably
maybe he wasn't I don't know but we were
vying for my mom's
and we lived in a one-bedroom and they
slept in the same room and then it was
like just the next person that's when we
had to live in one of her boyfriends
houses that was nice it was my first
chance to live in a house but it was
never my space he didn't like the way I
tapped my toothbrush when I brushed my
teeth because he could hear it through
the wall I felt like I had a tiptoe all
the time I mean I just always felt like
everywhere we moved on my can we just be
just us so at 18 I moved out and Wow
I was lucky though because I mean that's
not why but I just I worked from the
time I was 15 I started I was a sample
lady at Vons would you like to try this
ranch dressing and I took my job serious
and they saw that and the guy at the
Vaughan said I want to offer you a
bagger position I was like yes I was a
little too young but he gave it to me
and then I got a job at the same time at
the warehouse when people used to buy
CDs yeah yeah I remember the ones and
then we got I got a hundred percent
customer service because people were
always floored that I knew every type of
music I was gonna say you really do have
it really I mean that's a great positive
to have you have such a I saw one of
your post not too long ago I think your
whole family went somewhere you were all
doing yet something about Jethro Tull
lonna teaching them about Jena little
boys think that the flute is lame girls
oh my but I'll never forget a customer
came in all white man he's like you
can't help me and I was like he was
trying to name a song I'm like that's
Lou Reed and he's like I was over in
this section but if you really want a
good album so I knew everything I mean I
had grown up with all of it you know I
grew up with my dad every time I was
like Martin Luther King Day we would sit
at the table he would have you know talk
about that I have a dream speech then we
listen to Aretha Franklin and he saw at
the table my dad was so connected to
every movement that ever happened he
just loves people and it all relates to
music and music has curated my whole
life like I could curate my parents
divorce to Fleetwood Mac like there's
certain songs that to this day break my
dire straights and then as I got older
and angry it was like wu-tang clan see
for me creatively I love the lyrics but
whenever I listen to music I start to
see like see
means I want to put together in yeah in
promos or movies or clips or shows like
I love I just love my first breakup like
the cure
I remember recording the same song over
and over and over I don't know double
cassette I gotta get that [ __ ] off the
radio yeah I mean I mean during that
time when they were got divorced it was
so traumatic but now when I look back I
could never imagine them married like
that's the crazy thing like I don't
remember going through a long period of
being like I wish they were together
yeah I was the same way at my parents
like it was a shock at first because
change was about to happen but then it
was like yes yes then you're like wait I
could manipulate the situation now like
I'm asked him for $20 you know what I
mean that type of thing there was a
little bit of that but I will say to
this day my dad never talked [ __ ] about
my mom
he always and they had fights and
blowouts my mom during that time she
left with her pride her thing was she
didn't have much she came here she
finished her high school diploma thing
went to SMC to be to learn how to do
hair she worked at what is also as a
coffee bean on Main Street used to be
the first banana republic those little
part-time job and she wanted to prove to
my dad that she could save money and one
time after like Thanksgiving or
something she had saved up on her own
from whatever little stuff she did from
clipping coupons
it wasn't even from working or anything
$1500 and she just wanted to be
recognized as an independent woman who
could do my mom just wanted more and she
was a state you know stay-at-home mom
basically so when she divorced my dad
all of that now that I'm older I could
look at her as a human being came to
fruition but I was a little girl who
just one of my mom right to look at me
all the time so she was struggling being
this individual and growing and I was
like in the crux of all of it to dealing
with like now I got a two house two
places to be I can't see my dad every
day now that was weird but we got
through it but I will say that the
unfortunate part is that she had to work
all the time now to make ends meet so
there was more freedom and it wasn't
like today you know she didn't know
where I was right yeah that was a good
kid but I was definitely running the
streets we used to be in so ninth Street
right here on 9th and Pico there's a
liquor store and we used to hang it on
night
Street and it was like all the taggers I
was our little crew and like drink and
my mom had a Subaru and every time I
would come by they'd whistle and they'd
be like the Subaru lavas bottom kind of
look for me I'd be like Jaime back there
Duggan I was like Jackie oh my god she
found me one time pull me by my hair
slapped me and my friends following me
because she wants to sleep over tonight
oh my it's not looking good for either
so we moved on from the hot dog and
everyone would do this to me at school
she's like mimic the slap shucks it was
so I don't know I was crazy like that
but she was out there trying to do her
thing
but that's when I started to dabble cuz
after that sleepover that I just told
you when the kids were making fun of me
that my grandma's carpet was too dirty
and we we don't we eat on paper plates
I'm like well it's better you just throw
it away that's when I started to realize
I I hung out started hanging out with
different friends I made friends with
all the Mexican kids and I felt
comfortable because their grandma's
house was like my grandma's house and no
one was judging and I had a great group
of friends but that led to like my
attraction was always probably towards
more the bad boy anyways but then it
turned into like I was getting I was
attracted to the gangsters and so I was
over here all cutesy my shorts
rollerblading down to the Marvis of
projects like not thinking like anything
about it I was hanging out and going to
these parties I just wanted to dance I
wanted to listen to hip-hop I wanted to
like go to these off-site wu-tang we
used to go to these little boot when
wu-tang was just coming up his little
wu-tang concerts and I was in that scene
and it came with its other stuff too
right it caught up and other things
that's the crazy part when people look
at me and I'm working with this
underserved youth and I have my harem
it's my PT hair PT a hair on as my kids
would call it they look at you and they
judge you right away it's like what
we're dealing with today everyone has
biases like you don't know me you don't
know what I've been through or just cuz
the shade of my skin or you have no idea
I feel like that all the time when
people try to like cut you off or get
silly with me at a place I'm like oh yes
do you think you know but that's how it
is even nowadays like people have their
biases and we're like that towards other
people is the same thing on the flips
people assume you know if you look a
certain way so cut and clean that you
don't have any history or yeah any
perspective on anything it's like well
maybe I don't have the same perspective
and I'm not taking away from yours but I
do have my own perspective I mean I'm
judgmental these days as a parent I see
a guy with a braided belt and his shirt
tucked and I'm like this guy [ __ ] kids
no hot dogs at their house that's gonna
be my role it's funny because I tell my
kids all the time when they were little
did anyone touch her pokey like we still
call them poking her house anyone touch
her pokey and I'll never forget the one
time you know my daughter was like I
think so Michael whoa times for bogey it
wasn't with a hot dog
was it with a hot dog or a cheese
sandwich so what age are you when your
dad gets the music store I am just semen
in his ball sack at that point well you
are in 1972 okay I thought it was fifty
years and you're only 40 40 so I guess
it would be Thanks what are you trying
to say man I'm thinking you're 10 but it
would have been bad well he it actually
started before that so 72 is like 1970 I
guess right that's exactly the 50 years
he started it on Lincoln Boulevard right
across from the Boys and Girls Club but
still the Boys and Girls Club now down
the street he started it with a film he
was doing photography in one little
studio and he had like his drum set in
the other studio and really he was
trying to have a he wanted to be a
booking agent like for musicians so he'd
take your headshot then he'd find you
gigs which cut to my dad still does that
today and he'll be 80 in July just
really yeah yeah well he still books
bands so then he started doing you know
he's trying to make money drum lesons so
he's doing you know one drum student now
doing his photography using two of the
offices up there there was a weird
little apartment building behind it
there was a blind guy that lived there
that they he used to help eventually
whatever was down in the retail area
opened up and
my so it was five years of him doing
that by himself
that's why ours our corporate entity is
called Fernandez talent and associates
Fernandez talent because that's what he
really wants what he started you know
wasn't trying to have a store or
anything my uncle came with his degrees
you know my dad doesn't have any that so
he's got his it's his brother yes my
uncle Victor it was a way to get him
here from Canada to get his papers and
all that stuff and he was like come help
but the business cuz you had a show you
had a job and I think he had it like
give $5,000 and invest in it so he was
like I'll do accounting and help am i it
was my uncle's idea Victor that they
have the retail shop and that is what
birthed the store where you could buy
instruments and rent and strenght to own
an instrument basically and then they'd
started doing repairs for instruments in
the back the school grew from my dad's
one drum student to now we're teaching
piano and clarinet and whatever so it
was run out of this tiny little space
and the Boys and Girls Club was across
the street so those kids would
skateboard over hang out play guitar I
mean we that spot was a hangout like my
dad used to be the old man that was kind
of like shooting alright that's enough
on that guitar and ain't ya no more
stairway to heaven to get out of here
whatever so you know bums would come in
there and play and stuff um and that's
where I like grew up my sister Rhonda
had her first job there my oh my both my
brothers all at that location I like
that location my mom slept pregnant with
on her back in that location with my
brother when she was pregnant with my
brother with me one of them she always
tells our story she likes to point that
out I'm pregnant on my back before I got
an apartment
she found the apartment on 4th in
Ashland which my dad still lives in
which is rent control it's the only
reason that he still lives there since I
was gonna say what's a 200 on it's crazy
but it's why the business is still here
we wouldn't he says it all the time it's
his retirement and my uncle lives in the
building too it was like
Melrose Place so there was mr. Hayes who
lived across the way when he passed away
my dad took that build that unit over
for like three hundred and eighty
dollars and that's where we all lived in
our first apartment I see so anyways so
that's how they started the business
they maintained it with inexpensive rent
and it just kept growing and eventually
about 25 years ago the space became too
small because you know we didn't have
enough lesson rooms to do lessons and
stuff so they found this space on 19th
in Santa Monica they never quite had
enough money for a down payment to buy a
building they kicked themselves in the
head now over it and I definitely do cuz
it's real expensive here
so they took but it was five we went
from like I don't know maybe 2500 square
feet
max maybe less to five thousand three
hundred and fifty square feet and it was
enough room to finally really build out
and do what they wanted to do so all
this time it's only been two location I
mean except I know you have Forest City
as well but for Santa Monica Music
Center it's only been this - Wow
whenever people go come in and they go I
remember you guys when you were on
Lincoln we're like oh you're like an OG
customer like they remember the old days
but we were there from they were there
for a long time like half half the time
and then maybe 15 years ago they and
they were doing really well and they
opened up Culver City but never bought a
building and that's what's been the big
constraint on the business I mean it's
as you know over 20 grand a month here
we used to sublet this back area there
was already like a law firm here so they
sublet it to them and then one day one
of the ladies a few times in a row
according to my dad didn't pick up her
dog [ __ ] and he and my dad would like
leave it on their door like their
renters we need that rent my dad's like
Larry David like um so they ended up
leaving and then we struggled with this
back area like we always had hodgepodge
renters and then yeah so I never wanted
to work for the family business
everybody the family worked I was like
no meanwhile you know I'm bagging
groceries working out whatever the
record store then I got a another job at
footlocker I'll never forget when I
showed up I showed up to footlocker
they're like you're not scheduled but I
was supposed to be a at the warehouse so
I had to wear my
your your full longer shirt at the where
I feel like could you put an apron on
I really thought making fun of me blow
my soul to dress like a referee we
should get paid cash out the register
Foot Locker at the end of the day and if
there wasn't enough for you you got paid
an order then you would have to like
wait the next day and the next day to
get paid but yeah so I didn't want to
work here I was in fashion tonight
eventually got a job at you know Charles
David and I wanted to be you know in
fashion I was like I don't need a job
here I moved out at 18 I was paying my
own bills all that I was going to
college full-time working full-time and
just never really wanted to work at it
it wasn't that I wasn't connected to the
music's or anything although you're a
hustler I love it I was just like I
don't want to work at the family store
you can't afford me that was always the
thing right so then as time went on and
I had kids that's one of my whole world
changed I mean I was on planes I was
flying I was doing you know I have my
six my 63 my seven doing insurance and
all that stuff making good money we had
bought a condo because I they offered me
to move out of that rent controlled
apartment we were already Louie and I
had just got married we were already in
escrow on a condo and they're like we'll
give you five thousand to move I was up
no we were already gonna move but they
didn't know that and I was like $25,000
or not moves they're like now I'm like I
know what you're charging for rent so
then they came back ten thousand then 12
Louie's like just take it so I am Erised
it on a sheet for him over five years I
was like this is what you're gonna make
in the next five years he came and gave
us $25,000 Wow well we bought a condo in
Englewood at the right time we bought
for 306 two years later we flipped it
for 382 that's nice and then we've
gotten to a house in Lawndale and I was
like keep up with the Jones it's like my
husband was just like oh [ __ ] hold on
I'm getting my bags like he grew up one
of ten in the projects and he's like I'm
fine in a one-bedroom or a five bedroom
I just don't want stress if it's
stressing you out let's not do it
so eventually at that that was when the
market market crashed
all that and my company got bought over
by a big bank and they laid the county
executive's off first but I was the last
person cuz I was pregnant with my second
kid so they were kind of like oh and my
boss was trying to help me out he's like
I know Briana's birthday's in December
so we're gonna wait for your layoff to
like mid-january and then they kind of
gave me a package at the end and I said
you know what I'm gonna step out and be
an independent broker I just didn't like
waking up and watching the stock market
real early I was breastfeeding with a
headset trying to keep my kid quiet you
know the whole experience was like this
is not what this was supposed to be out
I mean when Briana came out of my body I
remember I was like I had a blackberry
back then I was like I'll be back in 72
hours as soon as this ship heels up and
I'm gonna drop her off at Louie's mom's
house she raises all the grandkids and
that's it the minute she came into this
world I didn't want anyone to touch her
no one knew better not doctors not I
don't care we had a thousand
grandchildren I'm gonna make my own baby
food I became one of those people and it
changed my whole life I was like I want
to see every little thing that she does
I would see your supermom
dude I would sob in the car like a
little [ __ ] what I would leave for like
a 20 minute meeting I was the worst
salesperson after that because people
would be talking to me like all right
well this is great feel like well we
want to hear a little bit more like you
know what sucked my product go with
someone else my tits are all leaking in
the meeting I'm just like guy to come
home there was an earthquake one time
and I'm in the Aon building and the big
elevator and usually none of that [ __ ]
scares nice to make fun of people who'd
get scared like it's gonna birth quakes
whatever oh my god they like make an
announcement I'm like oh my god I got
kids like everybody does nobody know but
I have a baby I was like the only person
who had had a child but I just wanted to
be there with her so I finally told
Louie cuz I was working from home and I
would drive into an office but I'd have
to fly here and there and we were like
we couldn't all this [ __ ] I said I was
in dude we're gonna sleep train the [ __ ]
out of her she gonna cry for days and
then she you know sniffled a couple
times I was like there's another book
about the sleeping in the same bed as
really
for you you just you know you morph it
all around your kids so once that
happened I told him I said listen I just
I don't know I feel like I've always
wanted to have this nonprofit I know
it's lame I'm not gonna make any money
but I want to help kids who are
underserved find their passion through
music cuz my whole life could be curated
by music and if I could help one kid
find themselves through music that'd be
cool and he was like I grew up in the
projects without [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't care about this waterfall
in the backyard like we can bounce out
of here at any time it's up to you so we
were also looted like I had lost that
job so it was also like and we're a
couple months behind so we we moved to
an apartment it was so sad because all I
wanted was a house I didn't live in one
my whole life my parents didn't own a
home and I had finally got to that place
you know it was like the white picket
fence the house looked cool but when you
zoomed back from the neighborhood I was
in I could never afford it in the right
neighborhood
gangster's next door like popping your
[ __ ] white picket fence they're
actually cool they were like somebody
tried to steal your bike and I was like
there was a there was a house down the
street that was like a HUD house so we
would have rotating fellas and they were
always selling dope out of there and I'm
pregnant one time and this guy I see
that we lived at the end of the block of
two schools he was filming little girls
behind them and I'm eight months
pregnant and I'm karate kicked the [ __ ]
out of this dude in the balls
his lady comes out she's like this crazy
pregnant she calls the cops on me crazy
pregnant ladies like [ __ ] up my
husband they went into his home and she
ended up coming to my house crying
saying they found pornographic videos of
he had naked pictures of her daughter in
there I feel like I saved a life yeah
you say more than one but I was like
[ __ ] we can't be in this ghetto and then
I had to so much but Mike my uncle had
come out of jail my mom's brother and he
was in a rehab program where is his
rehab of all the places I'm not kidding
it's at the end of the block of my new
place and I'm like [ __ ] he's gonna see
me walking the dog he's like could you
wash a load of laundry I was like yeah
I had meth addicts tapping on my door
you know I was like oh [ __ ] do my white
it was crazy and I was like what why
can't I just like I get there but it's
never quite there you know it's like
it's not quite fair hashtag overlooked
but overlooked but yeah so then we gave
it all up and he was like honestly I
attributed to Louie just saying stuff
doesn't matter to me you're on some
crazy trajectory of when and how and
what you gotta be keeping up with the
Joneses [ __ ] it
so we moved to an apartment on Centinela
and it had an elevator so that was nice
but it was way smaller we had to get we
had two living rooms at the other place
so we had to get rid of a whole living
room of furniture I had sold all these
like suits and things cuz I was like I'm
giving up a whole life of wearing Gucci
shoes and prada shoes and carrying fancy
handbags to just be something totally
different and I it was so rough I'll
never forget I had bought some sandals
at Ross and he had a reference like he
was just asking me nicely like why don't
you get some new sandals I'm like what I
can't buy $7 sandals because it's your
money and not mine it was like so hard
for me so I mean that whole time where I
was just gonna be with the kids and live
simply lasted for a second I quickly saw
that as I'm taking - Briana - these
Mommy Me classes I'm like well [ __ ] I
could do that so this space in the back
I took a little bit from every little
Mommy and Me class I did we would paper
the walls kids would come in and paint -
like Mozart then we would read them a
story that would be a tactile event
afterwards and then we would have a
30-minute music class and it was great
it was called pitter-patter studios yeah
you're always really great about that
[ __ ] I just hustled it and I was like
well if I'm taking her to class may as
well make a thing out of it then as they
got older I was like I don't want to
[ __ ] open this to do well in Sundays
to do that class my dad started seeing
me like could you just help us a little
bit with marketing you're so good I'm
like now I'm not helping the store you
guys are whatever and then it was like I
finally realized I needed to get out of
the house I needed something but I say
get out of the house I brought them to
work I mean me grew up in a playpen at
the Culver City Music Center me trying
to work the store it was just to make a
little bit of my own extra
come I would ride a bike over there and
I said I'll just help at the store and
once I dug in and saw what they were
missing I was like I need to be a part
of the family business
so I started helping them with marketing
slowly it was like why don't we have the
school account like we've been here long
time while your dad pissed off [ __ ] out
of here know who you are
my uncle has had to do the cleanup he
was like ah you know it's don't worry
about him so that was the dynamic my dad
had lost his finesse of the days of the
handshake and all that were far gone and
my dad still runs that way today like
he's a good guy so don't like he gave me
the eye contact and that's enough so I
went in and just finessed that
relationship and it just grew from there
to my uncle saying you know what
there was I've been wanting to retire
and I think this is the moment and so I
was here for like five seven years I
mean it's kind of crazy yeah cuz Mia was
like a baby and then finally like like
October of 2018 was when we did the
official paperwork so like a year and a
half ago of buying over but it was
already happening of like the official
buy I bought out my uncle's portion and
when I say I bought out it was like an
arrangement through the business that
was always the thing like I don't have
any capital or whatever because by then
we had already moved to another
apartment in Santa Monica to be closer
to the kids which is now I live next to
darling Stella which which that was all
meant to be I mean it really was look I
want to say this because I say this to
you all the time but I want to say this
on here like and I said this in the post
- I love well first of all I love you I
mean you were such a like a sounding
board when I during the split and I was
all you always talked to me so calmly
and you always made me feel so good
about my anxiety of being a new dad and
new single dad at the same time and not
do and I was like I think I'm gonna come
to some of those female meetings you all
have and I'll be the one cry and all
that I'm like get the [ __ ] out of here
right but you've been great to me you've
been great to my family I just I love
you I love your family Louie with all
the help with all the others
here too but also I love you're a boss I
love that you're a female business owner
I love that the the money I pay for the
space back here goes to a family-owned
business that serves the community I'm
not giving it to [ __ ] remax are ya
opportunity that just you know does
whatever the [ __ ] they do with it you
know it really gives back and we have a
lot of ideas and plans for things back
here in this space I'm really excited to
be a part of it because I want to see
this business get back on its feet and
grow so why don't we talk about what
happened the other day and he's gonna
join us grab your headphones put your
headphones on so we can hit you have
your headphones and you back there hmm
I'm here would you man if I can hear you
you good so why don't you I want to tell
it two ways because I'll tell you what
I'll start with my what happened on my
end and the first time seeing you and I
want you to tell us why you got there
and what I mean so for me what was
happening during this was Sunday the day
of the riots and again I fully support
the movement I'm not you know this is
just what happened people want to know
there's been a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] going
and flying out there that's been false
information stuff so I want to clear up
some things on my am but it was probably
around 2:30 in the afternoon I'm on that
citizen app and I get an alert that the
Shell gas station a block away we're
still and I just were before that was
robbed at gunpoint then they set a place
on fire not a block away now I live off
of Santa Monica Boulevard which is an
easy street to go destroy if you're just
looking for destruction there we know
people weren't really going into the
residential neighborhoods as much and
then there's another armed robbery right
there so I texted Don I was like hey
this [ __ ] seems like it's getting crazy
and it's closed can I just bring her to
your place and she's like sure so on my
way to her place I figured well let's
just swing by the studio and see what
going on there but I had seen smaller
groups gathering at the CVS and all
these things I'm like huh and when I
pull up you're already outside and
you're like get her the [ __ ] out of here
you were crying you're like they're here
they're circling there's a guy behind
you right now they've already said
they're gonna come back so at that point
I listened to you and I leave and when I
Drive down Santa Monica I see what the
guy told us today I see 30 people
tearing that 7-eleven apart and they're
tearing all the businesses in there and
I just know at this point it's
definitely gonna happen it's a matter of
time so I get still over your girls are
with Donna I tell them I'm coming back I
get here and now you've got people out
on the corner and I just start running
up into the studio to grab what I can
grab I call any and I'm like Annie can I
just rip this [ __ ] out of here and leave
the cords what [ __ ] equipment up and
then and he's like I'm coming and he and
ash both who are here now show up which
I cannot I know I'm looking at the wall
over here but I can't thank you both
enough for coming to help out so you
know we're out there and what made you
come when you came because you you I
didn't think anything was right yeah
well first of all he started peacefully
and and then when the the trouble
started peaceful protests went south to
Venice the people that weren't so
peaceful came East but I never thought
it was gonna get past Lincoln like right
and and the thing is I just want to
point out that I'm very much aware of
the fact and if people aren't the
peaceful protest and the people
protesting maybe that weren't even as
peaceful had nothing to do with the
looters and the opportunistic there's
like multiple groups happening here
there's people who had it organized and
then there's some people that may even
be in the community that's not an
opportunity to get a TV or whatever and
so that's the unfortunate thing I had an
idea like most of us who had been
watching it on the news that something
might jump off but it's gonna be at the
mall what I mean maybe they'll get to
Lincoln but it's gonna be west of
Lincoln maybe they'll get to Main Street
I don't even know if they'll reach Abbot
Kinney because now you're LAPD so we
took our kids to the beach because I the
choppers were out it
loud it was all hovering rate where we
were no I didn't realize that it was
hovering because stuff was happening but
we walked down to station 26 with our
bikes we rode her bike sexually and
Louie had walked so we're there and he's
like this is eerie we filmed it we're
like oh my god there's so many choppers
it's kind of hard to enjoy the beach but
it was weird on the beach that day was
like everybody was in a bubble like we
didn't know what was going on I get a
FaceTime call well let me back up
Louie's boss had said the day before
lockup packages in the back customer
packages and he's like you should board
up your windows I'm like I'm not gonna
board we're in a doctor's office
district 19 blocks from the beach so
when we're on the beach my friend
Darlene facetimes me she had drove down
was in the scene she's in front of the
Vans door facetiming crying she's
screaming at looters don't do this don't
do this is not you don't want to you
know disrupt what's the protest like
please stop and she's showing she's like
there's they're shooting m-80s there's
tear gas there's people looting they're
smashing everything I'm like oh my god
and we're all sitting there talking to
her like this is horrible what they're
doing to the mall but again I not that
the big-box retailers deserve it but I
was like that's probably where they're
gonna loot the Michael Kors store the
Norseman whatever is that Saul so who
the National Guard drove down my local
street they don't protect the Nikes in
the Nordstrom's and the Bloomingdale's
the people have more money than God and
insurance out the [ __ ] ass right and
they're using all their resources all of
them and they're also tear gassing and
using like like aggressive force on like
the protests innocent people yeah like
oh but not someone at the Reg looting
right in front of you is this crazy I
mean if you watch some of these videos
that are out there like people are
dropping merchandise in the middle of
the street like they're just and they're
pulling up in cars and they don't even
they're not even covering their faces so
anyways so as that's happening I'm like
the people start talking about the curve
you had just bumped up you know it was
like five and I got two four and the
lifeguard is like hey like he's starting
to tell people there was a curfew so I'm
like let's get going so we're getting
our stuff we go to unlock the bikes and
we're trying to ride our bikes and I
hear protesters and I start to panic
because they're coming with signs but
then they're fine oh my god is
protesters okay then I hear smashing and
yelling in the background but I'm
cuz that's smashing what is that Breanna
can't ride her bike now because the
tires have been slashed like sliced
which is bizarre maybe has nothing to do
with any of this because why would they
just slice her little used kid bike that
has saran wrap on the seat but like it
literally has her not from a hotdog
though
no hotdog juice on it but we're walking
now we have to go 14 blocks so we get to
Main Street in it it was so bizarre
there was this beautiful
african-american woman that's all decked
out like a model being filmed with a
professional camera like walked
sauntering across the street they're
filming something and then these five
like white boy skaters combine they're
like [ __ ] 12 [ __ ] 12 and I'm like what
is [ __ ] well it's it's cuz means [ __ ]
the cops I guess I'm not really sure if
they're counting the letters I still
haven't gotten into the details of what
the 12 is but they're yelling and
screaming
Rayden Breanna and me sit like right in
my kids faces and they're scared now
Louise a block ahead cuz he had went
first to check out like let me go ahead
of you guys and see if there's like
people are throwing m-80s
so we are hearing boom boom and people
yelling then I hear glass shattering and
the surf shop on the corner and all that
and people are like running now and I'm
like oh my god so I just said girls I'm
becoming like the crazy mom that I'm
screaming at them avert your eyes do not
look at anyone in the eye just follow me
one in front one behind walked tight
we're going oh we have to walk all the
way up the hill with the bikes and stuff
so we just started hustling at home and
they're getting tired I'm like we got to
make it home hearing all the sirens so
we get home and Louise like let's go
check on the store and I'm like I don't
really think we need to he's like let's
just go check on the store did you call
them and tell them I said well I told
them to like move some stuff by the
window or whatever but so it should be
fine we get here it was like the
craziest timing we're coming up our
route you know we take seventeenth I
make a right on Santa Monica I look left
West and I'm like there's nothing going
on over here
I look right I see like a straggler
woman talking to some homeless people
near the store or she's handing them
something then now I realized she was
giving them a brick or whatever but
she's looking she now I go to make a
u-turn to come back around and kind of
checking out the scene and I noticed
that the pharmacy has been
smashed on one door and she's peering in
the window of my store and Louisa oh
look look look at my boss I'm like
abnormal and then five guys it was like
perfect timing are running towards the
back window with the crowbar just take
it and I just start laying on my horn
I'm screaming it was like watching
someone break into my house and my kids
are inside right and I'm screaming from
a primal place my phone is at 1% trying
to be charged I'm going stop please
that's my family business don't do this
and they have masks on they've got two
middle fingers up they're running
towards me and can hear [ __ ] you [ __ ]
whatever so Louise I go back and I'm
like no I'm scared now because I don't
know if they have a rocket you don't
know what they have yeah honestly I was
like I don't want to get it'll be my
luck I'll get hitting the exact spot in
your head and I'll be talking about it
my left nostril for the rest of my life
so I'm like panicking I'm also trying to
tell scenario to call 9-1-1 and it's
like call numb mom and I'm like now
[ __ ] it's like I might call 9-1-1 it's
like call your mom I'm like now so he's
trying to like film them film them and
we're like shaking so I come back back
around and I notice that there's like a
Range Rover who's following and honking
at them so they they ran away so we come
across at the Maserati dealer and the
owner and this other guy he's like hey
dudes and one guys like get out of here
man they've been shooing people away but
they're coming and they already hit the
pharmacy and the other guys like don't
get out of here go stand in front of
your business go get some friends get
over there and I'm like oh my god so the
other guy starts telling me they just
hit my pharmacy he's already got guys on
the way with like boards so as we're
doing that two cars block me they're
like racing around my crew that coming
fast and I just hurt the detector just
tell me the other day about a call that
someone else is calling in seeing me be
blocked in is kind of hanging it from
the perspective like she's like we got a
call it's like she's being blocked in by
to cry and it was scary because he was
behind me and I was out of the vehicle
like talking to them like oh my god so
we go over there and Louie's like all of
them right you can see everything in
there like if you put your face and you
see all these saxophones and guitars and
everything so he's like we got to get in
there so I do this I have this group
text called hot moms and some I like PTA
moms and I'm like everyone it's somebody
help and I love them cuz they will come
I mean you could be like I got tired
and they're there with ammonia to cut to
like we're being looted and they're like
they're there with a baseball bat and a
bicycle helmet so they ran over right
away to my close friends Adi and Ashley
they were like do you need us there now
we're in the car so they show up and
then two more friends come and I'm
panicking inside trying to scribble on a
piece of paper do I do I say out of
business and then you know they're like
my friends like say minority-owned I'm
like well that's something a minority
probably wouldn't put on the window but
you know weird what do we say do we say
there's nothing in here we're drawing
the blinds we're like trying to paper it
up we're also trying to move stuff as
much as we can and then now there's
these little groups coming and I have
pictures of it from me inside of a car
pulling up and they're straight coming
we're tapping on the window and there's
only three friends outside they can only
do so much my one friend god loved her
Raquel she's yelling she's give a [ __ ]
she's like get out of here go home you
know she's trying to shoo them away and
at this point they seem like groups of
five young punk kids who if you're
standing there they're gonna go away and
that's kind of what it was at first
backpacks on the front in the back
they're ready to loot but they're not
trying to get in into it with anyone cut
- cars are zooming down the street full
speed people are sitting outside the
windows with crowbars hammers whatever
they can tap windows it's coming it's
like so my friend my friend's husband
Patrick is like I mean while I'm still
in my bathing suit and like my daisy
dukes and my flip-flops he's like okay
if you're gonna stand out here you can't
be wearing that so go change so we get
in the car
we're going westbound on Santa Monica
Boulevard we get five blocks west on
14th to make a left and there is
pandemonium it's like 60 people looting
the crap out of this adult sex shop like
driving over dildos I was just thinking
like how do you resell that underwear
just so you know if you bought them the
loss of the other guy somebody said they
saw them with like a plastic one of
those dolls just carrying out
but they were hitting the vape shop in
there and I talked to them and I just
found out that they broke the guy's
wrist at the vape shop and apparently
the the guy from the sex shop like had
just left and was like hiding in the
back or something for an hour so that's
scary but my friend owns Truxton is our
favorite restaurant we make a u-turn and
I'm like oh they're they're looting
places you can get stuff but then I see
them smash the front windows of trucks
sins and I'm like oh [ __ ] they're coming
like there's a smashing [ __ ] now so I
call my friends and I'm like you guys
they're already panicking hey they're
coming this way and I want to say this -
real quick not to interrupt you but this
is coming off the heels of being kalokhe
clothes for months for like everyone's
forgotten about the coronavirus like
we've been out of work and we you and I
both for months because of this and
honestly how many days were you open
when Friday they said we could be open
two days two days Archie was Friday
night when they finally said it really
you look at day and a half open to the
public again and maybe you can get some
business rolling back in and boom so
Annette kerbside for the music industry
doesn't exactly right yeah we're not
hamburgers and pizzas I'm not throwing a
$3,500 saxophone in someone's window
from the curb right that's not how those
purchases happen so anyways we see them
coming we call them to tell them that
they're coming and they're like we know
there's a group coming the opposite
direction they just looted CVS and
they've got carts and the whole thing
and there's car because there's lots of
cars or circling
so I'm like don't I don't I don't want
anybody risking their life for you know
the whole thing at that point someone
brandished a gun and that's when my
friend was like I just had a gun shown
to me he told me so I didn't see that
gun he said somebody just got out of
their car and like basically showed the
sidewalk the gun like we're common he
just said because he had a bat I think
it was more to protect me if something
happened and a bicycle helmet he was
probably like just go to t-ball or
something
smash-and-grab sale they'd said so he's
like um you know what are you gonna do
with that do you end up getting shot so
that's when it got real like you know no
one wants to get hurt anyways but guns
come out you know you know the pharmacy
that's across from us SMC pharmacy
within minutes they
guys with bulletproof vests Israelis
almost surround and ar-15s and also
you're a pharmacy you know they're
coming you know they're coming thank you
because it's compound pharmacy for like
hormones I always think I'm like what I
was like all right there's probably like
some codeine ibuprofen I don't know and
then you gonna go the dildo shop I'm so
confused
took me a minute they did have ar-15
though they did they were ready to go
but that's what you needed if you and
listen after 17 calls to 9-1-1 they
basically said listen if you own a
registered firearm a we're not coming
out here if there's guns being shown and
if you own a registered firearm you are
more than welcome to protect your own
property that's what I mean I was
texting everybody like if you have a
legal registered firearm we need help
well that's when I I came back I started
hustling what I could out of here any
and ass show up doing the same and it
was begin it was impending dude like it
felt like zombies were here and we were
all about to go under and you just so so
many things were going on back to what
you were saying like there were five
helicopters low hovering all day the
cars left and right this 19th streets a
weird wide streets like almost like a
three lane and they were rolling in five
six deep and I want to make it very
clear it was not that you say all black
be [ __ ] every race was represented
in what I saw in the back some yes I'll
say this if I'm gonna generalize
anything it would be age and the
overwhelming majority of the people I
saw were young young people and it
started getting crazy at that point you
had left Louis took you home and you I
called you and you were like just get
the [ __ ] out of there it is will you
call me on the way you're like it is
madness they are coming they're coming
they're coming
you went home we're still doing our
thing and then it you could see the
crowd get you could see a crowd getting
bigger and bigger
and your friend that drove the Subaru Oh
Raquel oh she got her windows so she
came back yelling that they're coming
they're coming get the [ __ ] out of here
and I go what the hell happen to your
window and she's like - it was two white
girls fluffy slippers yeah brandy
melville shirt so what happened was when
when the cars are pulling up they start
looting the stereo alarm store a few
doors down but they're just cavalier in
the way they're doing they've parked in
Santa Monica in the middle of the street
and now they're clogging traffic for
people that are coming through that
don't know what the [ __ ] going on and
they're terrorizing people in the street
these little white girls with hammers
busting through windows and [ __ ] and you
just see more and more people rolling up
and I'm telling you and and it's getting
closer and closer Louie has come back
he's standing on the corner he and I are
out there any an Asscher still hustling
things out - and at that point when they
finally got out when she came back with
her windows all smashed out and then it
just seemed like a hundred people on
foot and again five six deep in car
after car after anymore nice cars by the
way lock the fire truck from making a
left and tag the back of their truck
yeah that's what you told me tagged that
truck so you've got fire sirens going on
it was so disorienting it was like a war
zone here that nobody no car no one
helping us it's it's it's going to have
it's inevitable and I keep circling to
tell Louie like I'm right here the car's
right here I'm done now I'm in the car
you're telling me to get him I got the
door open I'm like you can jump in I
swing to the other side and I purposely
positioned myself up front so I can't be
blocked in because I see people coming
behind me and everything and I go to get
like anything I can of this on camera
and a guy sees me and I've told I've
mentioned that there was a gun pulled on
me there was but I want to make it fair
if you ask my friend back home they held
me down at the bottom of the steps of
the bazooka on my neck it made me watch
while they took off much it did not go
down like that I've talked to the
detective a guy saw me he took a gun he
had it right here against his chest like
this and he goes get the [ __ ] out of
here and I'm sorry used
or but I am quoting but I just circle
around and I tell Louie like look cuz he
was still on the corner and didn't see
it it was between him and me and I gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here everybody
there's guns just get the [ __ ] out here
and that's when I left I left before and
he still didn't leave which pissed me I
was he drove across right at that point
I left because it was happening and you
were like get the [ __ ] over here I want
him to get a bag and but there was no
gun pointed in my face there was no
anything like that and you know and also
part of me we're not later I was like
secure borrowing his martini rowdy uses
this scream like as I'm cutting but um
you know it and the detective she asked
me like what did he listen it was like
the purge it was like Mad Max normally
you stand out with a mask
everyone had masks Halloween type [ __ ]
the skeletons like intimidating scary
[ __ ] and the gun wasn't I know it sounds
crazy but it wasn't that big of a deal
but you couldn't you were overtaking in
that yes I've seen it in Baltimore one
time and I've told the story on the
podcast it was a it was a bar fight that
rolled out about 15 people but it moved
down the street and all the sudden more
Pete and I we were like holy [ __ ] and
quickly accrue to like 40 fighting and
angry people to see that to see to
remember I drove Stella to her mom's
first I saw 30 people when I saw what
looked and felt like a hundred [ __ ]
people and foot out there and then
there's everywhere and people exiting
the cars on you can see they look we
talked about it it felt very organized
it felt like the I talked to a friend in
New York I didn't mention anything to
him he said the same thing it felt like
the first wave was sort of hitting the
[ __ ] and then the next wave comes with
the backpacks
I saw people with suitcases they left
the church everyone's like oh this is a
great Church kinda sweet but the glass
yeah I was on wheels I was like no they
were using that to move merchandise I
mean yeah so I saw everyone represented
in there but the and again if I'm gonna
generalize none of these people
I understand what's going on with the
anger and the rage and all of it I get
it I do understand why they weren't part
of that they were people say opportunist
but that's almost sounds positive these
people were just out for destruction and
mayhem and again I saw a probably of 19
20 year-old a white blond girl driving a
cura SUV like this was not a you know
you couldn't racially profile
no [ __ ] way and also it's so
difficult to identify anyone people did
it right we're covered you couldn't tell
age race sex nothing on some of these
people so you know it was a [ __ ]
scary thing and all but it was that's
what I told the detective the mob of the
and I mean that like literally the group
of people that moved almost like a
[ __ ] amoeba up the street but then on
top of it you got helicopters going
you've got sirens left and right you got
screaming and yet the shot the gun in
the air two times we didn't know that
though yeah after I was he was how far -
did you scare people it did not scare
anybody no it didn't scare anybody so
any I want to hear your take from when
you pulled up here I mean first of all
you you think this for coming through I
mean we built this with you man like we
know all the all the time and the effort
and the money that you put into this I
mean we we had to save it it wasn't it
wasn't a question when we got the call
it was the craziest thing to hear you
didn't even say hello I said I started
to say alone you said the looters are
here so I mean it was it was instant for
me it was like the decisions already
made you know it's just a matter of how
far did you get and what more do you
need and you obviously needed our help
and we came through immediately and I
mean you did I can't again I love you
guys for that you really do you did not
have to and I know what you're saying
but man thank you know for sure man like
for sure we didn't feel like we had to
but it we felt like because that was
crazy when you got here it was
Hevy yeah it was it was really starting
by the time you pulled up yeah bye
before we even got here we on the I put
it on my Instagram story on the on the
gas State at the gas station like right
down the street was the armed guards and
there was just
oh really 40 of them just casually in
there we saw him in the back of the
truck just in Santa Monica yeah yeah
we're not coming down here you know
crazy at the Maserati shop Louie was
like there was eight cops in there at
one point and there's nobody in there no
one broke into the Maserati shop which
is across the street you know caddy
corner yeah and I'm like why are they in
there like but just not looking over
here you know and I was on the call with
the police chief so there's some insight
and I can see but I just to me it was
crazy to see what it feels like to have
no I mean you're calling and they're
like we're just not gonna come I mean
you got guns across the street you got
the owner here saying he's got a gun I'm
seeing a gun Richard saw a let me tell
you something I never saw that in
Baltimore City okay this is liberal ass
Santa Monica so think about that exactly
and that's you know that's a whole other
thing politically people are like you
know I got everything after that Fox
News report came out people are
commenting let's if you get your
liberal-ass you don't even know me first
of all say this loud and clear
Republicans don't own guns I mean excuse
me don't own the Second Amendment they
don't own the second gun they don't own
the Second Amendment there was plenty of
liberal didn't get looted because of him
and you know well then the next night
was van eyes when that that family was
out on the car on the sidewalk what
their debt was out by you guys anyone
the sidewalk they protect it yeah they
had a liquor store so they just stood
out front with their shotguns and then
the police show up now look I know it's
got to be weird and confusing to roll up
and see a family of people with shotguns
telling you they went that way what the
[ __ ] are you all doing though but the
news lady was there the whole time
saying the looters are running it's not
how and they remember they cuffed them
and everything else so once they saw
what happened to Santa Monica and that's
the other thing I want to mention too is
I've told a lot of friends about this
who live here and they're like didn't
hear any of this on the news I said I
know they're well
can tell you it it cuz there wasn't a
[ __ ] news crew around you're gonna
have a news crew do [ __ ] on the news
down there talking about the white girls
robbing the surf stores and [ __ ] orbs
and store yeah listen and I feel sorry
for the couple that has the optometry
place on 4th Street and the Sakai house
but let's not get it twisted if you
could afford property down there I mean
you're probably doing a little bit
better than those of us that have to be
east of Lincoln this part of the
community has always been overlooked we
paid the same taxes we pay all that
stuff you know we have a homeless issue
it's like we gotta wait longer 1999
South Bundy
is right there that is the Fox News a
fox head cord is that but no one in
there let me not till after that but but
also the story that we're sharing is our
story and I'd say maybe it's a five
block radius
imagine what was going on in every
neighborhood across this nation that
[ __ ] during all this during but our
police so much uncovered it was so much
uncovered and our police was they said
you know we weren't prepared and
apparently like and this is all public a
sheet the chief went on a zoom call at
the community and I was upset because
I'm like how could you say that it you
didn't you heard information that it was
canceled and so you didn't feel like you
needed to have tactical groups if one
thing tells you that it's still
happening and ten say it's don't go with
the one that says it isn't now to her
defense apparently you know she's
working off of a budget restriction so
every thirty minutes of overtime they
got a log it so she's not wanting to put
together some overtime tactical crime
like who the hell thinks about [ __ ]
overtime when you're I mean if that's it
well we were on the phone she's like
look I'm at twenty eight minutes right
now I got to wrap this off I was like I
haven't even gotten to the hard part yet
no I mean this is like you know this was
like the crazy thing that oh you know
they're like not a life was lost not cuz
he use cuz this is some of these
[ __ ] at ar-15 I think that's
why I mean and maybe because we're
liberal Santa Monica nobody popped off
their gun cuz it could have been a
exchange but also the people that were
destroying things again I don't think
they were out to kill ninety five
percent of them won't even armed and
didn't
have anything I think there was a couple
who knew that they were coming to a town
that was scared to death of baby flash
yeah they're like living which is what I
saw Birkenstocks and tie-dye shirts
they're like let me show them my water
pistol you know I mean maybe that's what
it was we were taken advantage of
because you know there's this ideology
of like who we are because people were
definitely coming from out of town I
think they were looking look there's
that last video that the neighbor gave
me the girl is like the one who's
running up the street with two goons
yeah well this is a different one where
she's parked waiting and she's texting
when the other car comes and then they
hand her something with liquid in it and
I'm like damn we probably could have got
set on fire which would have really
destroyed everything inside but it was
so much planning and I don't think they
really knew the area so they drive
around find a spot and then you'd see
cars comes resume they'd give you
something to break the window well it
was so sad about it is like when you're
watching it people kept saying it's just
stuff just be glad that you're okay I'm
like but it's not just stuff it's my
whole livelihood like I don't think they
understand they might be under the
auspice of thinking like oh they have
insurance and it covers it well as we
know it's not that easy and even if it
does you're still left with stuff that
insurance just doesn't cover you know
interruption of business and things like
that us all the time we've been down for
Corona and not having any money come in
for three months no it's a delayed
another however many months and windows
I didn't come on and then just a 0% I
wanted to tell these people I had to put
on a 0% credit card and get Meghan my
friend and haggle with guys I slept in
this whole place for two nights when
they redid the carpets Louie and I moved
things because we couldn't afford to
have a crew we had to pay people cash to
do it after work just a sweat equity
that went into it and the sweat equity
that then had to go in to clean it goes
back for decades with your family in
this neighborhood serving the community
and that's what I've said to you -
there's so many good people coming out
of the oh my god but that's those are
the seeds you've planted and now the
fruit is bearing and let people help you
I mean listen when I came here first of
all my friends husbands like Lana do you
have another broom or whatever Mike
where are you he's like I'm here he they
were there before me sweeping the glass
up at six o'clock in the morning and I
had
koffie brought to me I mean from food
and water to friends coming to help
clean off the graffiti and just
everything I well any go back I want you
to tell your your side of things to
please so so so once we got here
honestly my biggest fear was getting
mistaken as one of them because we went
around like you said they were like kids
and little white girls and boys and
stuff so I mean the fact that you didn't
know who was who was the good guy who
was the bad guy you know me carrying
around a gun it felt safe against
looters it did not feel safe again yeah
anybody else so that was probably the
craziest part but by the time we got
here you you were already hustling so
our main our main agenda was just - just
a hustle with you I mean this room
behind me used to look but yeah we took
everything then we you know it went from
what is what's vital you know what what
should we take first - let's let's take
it all so it was just up and down the
stairs and then it was like it's still
the windows are all boarded up so it's
yeah we were able to salvage almost
everything which is really good
barricade and then we barricaded like
like a [ __ ] tornado was coming week
whatever God did I told Eddie I was like
if they were if they want it they're
gonna have to earn all right they're
gonna have the art like now that now
it's good because you'll be able to have
that 24/7 security I mean a guard you
have cameras all that rings all that
[ __ ] is here now as a forward and the
cameras that we have already like all
the footage or zoom in it right and as
that's the other thing it doesn't matter
you know what I mean like people like
did you have an alarm yeah it went off
when they crack the [ __ ] clay like if
they're coming in they're coming here's
the harm some cameras don't matter yeah
but also that night too like it was
about I don't know it's like 11:30 and I
was out front smoking a joint it was
everyone had gone to bed and then I saw
you pull out now Segal wonder where
Lana's going you call me you're like hey
my friends own a construction thing and
I'm gonna go board up so I went in and
told Donald I can't I want to go help
and I was it was I was glad I wanted to
come here and help up and board up it
was just because also you didn't know if
anyone was still coming around or if
anyone was still in here and was it was
only a few hours after but the other
thing too that was crazy about all this
is we're talking about 4:30 5 o'clock it
was broad [ __ ] daylight bright as
[ __ ] it was and it was scary and and it
went on until sundown like that's it was
a long that was the thing it wasn't like
a one-and-done
it was like a and then we were driving
home they were gun shops driving around
the neighborhood burning cars yeah so we
weren't sure if they were gonna start
hitting and I wasn't I was like thank
God I live in a shitty apartment
buildings I was ready to get a hotel we
don't need a security gate that's why
they don't paint it that's exactly what
we thought when when when it went to Van
Nuys the next day I mean we definitely
don't live in a super nice place so yeah
we heard nothing but gunshots the entire
night we're like I mean we're not coming
here though right I know that's what
kind of made us feel safe isn't my
husband growing up in the projects he's
like [ __ ] I used to warm up the car and
go back in the house and put hair gel on
everybody knows my family well I want to
UM please will you mention the GoFundMe
um let's plug everything right now and
get it all out there so I mean some
amazing parents from that they're called
snappa it's the Santa Monica the visual
and performing arts like parents
together they put together like that was
the crazy thing at 8 o'clock in the
morning they're like we've got a URL
it's help Santa Monica music dot org I'm
like wow it points to a GoFundMe there's
to go foamies and they're both
legitimate and they both are needed
because one friend started one Holi
right away then another group said they
reduced the amount so that together
maybe I don't make a song I was like
damn I should have left it for more but
you because you don't know until you get
a forensic CPA person in here from the
insurance company to tell you your vote
so even after so that's helped Santa
Monica music org also we didn't mention
this but the lab that I was starting
back here with the you know Logic Pro
and the Ableton Live and the DJ stuff
the DJ coach with DJ hapa we were just
starting this partnership which we had a
pivot and move things online so we have
the DJ coach which is a class you can
still take that's a great way to support
us sign your kids up for the summer camp
we got going on our website there's a
link for the DJ coach
it's ranges from age to six and up you
know to the novice to the person who's
been DJing and wants to learn more from
a professional but outreach through the
arts is our nonprofit arm where we serve
kids on free and reduced lunch through
private music lessons after school we do
group ensemble stuff we have other
classes I've been on-site at schools
helping kids who are you know
underserved youth that may be college
isn't an option for them so if I could
introduce them to music production to
make money to have a real job that was
my goal and 16 year old Ryan Sickler
would have killed for something like you
in my life
yeah I mean like we were just hopin I
were talking today cuz I made a comment
about like well not that you know DJ's
the queer he's like wait AB and maybe
gets 302 playing and they got a split
with six people yeah a DJ will for sure
make $300 and we can show you how to get
there and it's it's about finding
something for kids that make them want
to do it that they're happy they're
passionate about it and in in even here
with the podcast and teaching them how
to do the control room well we're gonna
do that look I am a huge fan of the
underdog the hashtagged overlooked and
obviously the [ __ ] honeydew nonprofit
that it's OTT a rtas oh my god hot dogs
Oscar Meyer OTT a RTS org that's odda as
which sounds for outreach to the arts if
you want to donate to that nonprofit
it's all directly funded to that program
and that will help continue the program
because the store needs rebuilding but
we were housing the nonprofit in here so
those this is where these kids came for
them well that's what we talked about
like we want to have these kids come in
and learn how to live switch and shed it
and shoot cameras and do podcasting is
only growing and growing growing so I'm
very excited to be part of that because
I want to help and just to be cool and
be like oh learn this cool thing this is
a reality it is so expensive to live
I've got two stepdaughters that are
struggling you know they've got great
setups with departments luckily but it
would be a struggle to live with two or
three I know I know
I mean we're stuck in a rent controlled
apartment um so I want to give kids an
opportunity to be independent
listen of someone who's this has been a
humbling experience to having people set
up a GoFundMe I revel in the fact that I
can do for myself I've always been
independent and keeps on me just say
thank you let people they want to help
you but I want to give these kids that
independence if you own age if you have
a trade a skill and you're passionate
about it you're gonna be successful and
if I can harness that passion and give
them a real skill that you could
actually make a living from that to me
is like helping in so many different
ways it's not just the feelgood's of
like oh come play some music it's like
no let's let's really hone into that and
have you build a life for yourself where
you don't have to depend on anybody you
can set your own schedule it's okay [ __ ]
skill college debt afterwards I'm you
know what let me say this if anyone's
out there in the LA area and you want to
help out reach out email me Ryan at Ryan
Sickler com
we're gonna get this thing going here
shortly hopefully I'm not sure how long
it'll take before everyone's back up and
running but if you want to help out
email me and we could use the help yeah
maybe even come in and help out the kids
and everything else I think it's great
Ilana thank you for coming on any Ann -
thank you as well I keep looking at the
wall
one more time with your websites give
the website okay well there's where
Santa Monica music.com so that's our
website for the store we own call for
city music - and you can access the
GoFundMe from there - there's a pop up
also the nonprofit but help Santa Monica
music org is helping us rebuild right
now we need way more than we thought
because you know interruption of
business is the biggest problem and OTT
arts org is outreach through the arts
that's the nonprofit so if you want to
help sponsor some kids you want to help
us rebuild it all coincides you know
let's help I love you listen to me
you're the [ __ ] thank you for doing this
I know this way of course I know I'm
like okay you're gonna get packages of
hot dogs and [ __ ] my go-to now bigger it
is bigger fat well thank you again I
love you for everything and I look
forward to all that we're gonna do back
here we're just gonna that's the other
thing I just had got the first episode
reporter we're just getting started so I
can't wait to see where we're gonna have
a good time and help a lot of people
pointing at the wall Ryan Sickler on all
social media Ryan Sickler comm make sure
you subscribe for the patreon show and
submit your story and make sure you
subscribe to the YouTube channel so you
can watch the honey-do there every
Tuesday we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]